predictably the establishment is blaming
president trump and his supporters
for a climate of rage and hate but let's
be honest
a lot of americans have had a lot to be
angry about for an awful long time
i'm thinking in particular of african
americans whose long struggle for
freedom may have been one decades ago
but whose struggle for genuine equality
and opportunity and dignity and fairness
is a long way from over a very long way
i'm also thinking of working americans
especially those outside
the booming centers of the modern
knowledge economy whose economic
security has collapsed his economic
opportunities have disappeared and his
social fabric
especially family and community has been
ripped apart
that's been going on since at least the
early 1970s
that's nearly half a century this anger
we're seeing it didn't start with donald
trump
i think it goes back at least a decade
in 2008 you saw
the elite bail themselves out while
working people paid the price for their
recklessness and incompetence and you
saw
a new tone enter our politics before
then
we had presidents who whatever their
political views made clear
they loved america and loved americans
all americans
reagan the bushes bill clinton they
weren't haters
you got the sense they loved everybody
bilkington perhaps a bit too much
but then we saw something new a cultural
elitism came in condescension even
contempt
like this
or religion
and this for the first time in my
adult lifetime i'm really proud of my
country
we saw hate and divisiveness from the
top
and remember from the left not the right
from the elitists
not the populists from joe biden
they not you have an ally in the white
house
this time they have an ally they're a
small percentage of the american people
virulent people some of them the drugs
of society
and of course from the queen of hate the
empress of divisiveness
you could put half of trump's supporters
into what i call the basket of
deplorables
i have never heard republicans talk
about fellow americans like that
president trump has never talked about
fellow americans like that yes
he's used harsh language about illegal
immigrants or ms-13 gangs too harsh at
times for sure
but he's never talked like that about
the people of this country
ever since 2008 working americans have
started to realize that the people at
the top
the politicians and the ceos and the
tech geniuses and the hollywood types
they really do look down their noses at
them for how they live what they eat
what they watch the fact they go to
church
and of course their political views i
know this is true because i'm part of
the elite
i sit at their dinner tables and hear
how they
speak so let's tell the truth about the
roots
of this rage i want to say something
directly to my friends in the elite
this is not just about trump it's about
you
too the way you've shown no compassion
for the casualties of your ideas the
human casualties
of globalization automation
centralization and uncontrolled
immigration
your ideas have destroyed people's jobs
devastated their families and
communities
and then in 2016 when they cry out for
help
you call them deplorable as eric holder
would say you kick him
the elites have enthusiastically jumped
on a
tweet from tom hanks today he was in the
pittsburgh neighborhood where this
terrible synagogue shooting took place
which happens to be the neighborhood
that mr rogers lived in tom hanks just
played him in a movie
hank saw this sign in a window love thy
neighbor
no exceptions well yes
and that applies to you in the elite too
here's my plea
to the liberal elite and the never trump
elite start practicing
the tolerance that you preach show some
empathy
and respect for your fellow americans
love thy neighbor yes even the ones who
support president trump
and watch fox news tell me what you
think of that
at steve hilton x and at nextrev fnc